so whether you're in sales you run a
sales team or your business owner that's
dealing with a sales squad today's
videos for you so look I mean in the
evolution of business you're going to go
through these four steps I've been
saying this for a while you got to learn
how to go from employee to sales then
you got to learn how to go from being a
salesperson to become a sales manager
Sales Leader then you become a business
owner then you become a CEO but just
like back in the days and 60 70s nobody
went to the top of a company without
learning how to sell I want you to take
that approach for yourself and your
business and your company so what is the
secret to scaling your sales force or
your sales team see a lot of times I see
a lot of guys that are great motivators
they want to learn how to motivate I
want to be a motivational speaker and
motivational speakers as effective as it
is motivation is simply temporary
enthusiasm inspirational speakers could
be long-term enthusiasm but both of them
have a problem and here's what the
secret comes in what is the problem so
imagine I'm sitting there the guy said
you can do it you're amazing go get them
gone all this a phenomena call men I
feel so good
I feel I can't wait to go home and do I
don't know what to do when I go home
that's a motivational speaker and the
inspirational speaker yeah we're gonna
go out to make a difference we're gonna
do this oh my gosh I want to make a
difference I only go out there and be
part of this long-term but but then what
do I do to make money and win and that's
when you get the drivers drivers learn
how to get people to get results so they
stick around with the inspiration to get
to where they need to get to and today
I'm going to talk to you about the
secret to how great sales leaders and
great entrepreneurs who run their sales
team or learn how to drive better than
the rest so let's get right into it
first things first number one in order
to be a great driver of a sales team you
got to have moral authority what is
moral authority you got to be somebody
that I am willing to give you permission
to drive me it ain't the other way
around so this was not like a boss
situation I was at an insurance a
meeting a couple weeks ago and one of
the conversations that was brought up
about a company I said what's going on
with that company he says that company
doesn't have a
good sales leader and because of that
they absolutely lost everything last
week I was in Miami on Friday I'm
meeting a guy that runs a business doing
one hundred million dollars a year we go
meet with them and he says one of my
companies collapsed and it doesn't work
anymore we lost the company I said what
happened he said I hired a wrong Sales
Leader so he's not in tune with sales he
trusted another Sales Leader boom he
loses the company another one locally
here in Dallas the guy's worth 1.6
billion he meets with me he says can you
give me some good sales leaders because
myself ever since I bought the company
for 80 million dollars a company he
bought sales has been like this because
he hires a Sales Leader that talks a big
game they're great motivational
inspiration but they don't know how to
drive number one is moral authority what
is moral authority you're in work every
day so you got your responsibilities
their responsibilities you're direct
you direct them on what to do here's
what I'm directing you how to do Bobby
they need to be coachable your example
what is the example I come and I work
I'm in there with you we're going to do
this thing together I'm willing to be a
student the person that you're leading
next you're being honest because you
cannot direct somebody and drive
somebody without being honest sometimes
the motivational speakers and sometimes
inspirational speakers all they want to
do is to make sure everybody feels good
and you can't just have an environment
where everybody is just feeling good all
the time it's like being high all the
time but no one's moving I'm going to
same exact place a driver is going to
say listen let me simplify for your
pretty bad on the phones and if you go
like this on the phones you are never
going to make it in sales what do you
want to do you're horrible on the phones
yeah you can be good because I saw some
of the things you said it was good but
right now we gotta learn the script some
set in for me let's go through it
together we learn hey let me tell you
something over here your work ethic if
you go like this nothing's going to be
happening because I see your suspect
every want somebody show up when you
feel like it if it rains you don't come
to the office if it snows you have an
excuse if a car breaks every single day
your car breaks down somes going on that
can help you with that so you got to be
willing to be honest the driver and the
other person has got to be willing to be
open and taking them by the way if
they're not then that's a whole
different stuff we'll be talking about
but number one is moral authority a
great Sales Leader
has a moral authority if you have moral
authority people are willing to listen
to you moral authority comes with prior
success existing success everyone in the
marketplace knows who you are
everyone knows how hard you work
everyone knows where you're going
everyone knows the types of people
you've developed that I've also made
money and have been successful so
there's a reputation that anybody who
works with you they become successful in
sales anybody that gets close to you
they become successful themselves and
then everybody wants to run what's your
secret is to teach and everybody that
maybe is getting better results in
somebody else just right now Lewis back
here Lewis who did you tell me what's
your favorite player of all time Vince
Carter right and you obviously are not a
big LeBron James member your big lens
Carter fan okay I'm proud of it so then
I asked a question I said hey Louis who
did who coach Vince Carter so I had
brantford here my buddy from the Army
and Lewis start going through the list
of people that coached Carter and you
can come up we had sandwich decent
assembly was a good coach some of these
other guys but nobody that was a
Popovich Riley or a field a Carter's got
to be coached by some of these guys now
some people say he was lazy he did not
disappoint he partied the ladies all
this other stuff I think a lot of these
other guys are like that as well
sometimes moral authority with a coach
that knows how to drive and get the best
out of people is what the differentiator
is between you not making money and you
making money so you as a sales person
that wants to build a sales team you got
to learn how to be a sales really number
two you get judged in your entire life
you and I get judged based on who we
pick we get judged and how we read
people we get judged on our intuition of
our friends of our girlfriend of our
spouse of our career of the place we
live of the place we build up every
single thing you are judged on who you
pick so in the world of sales leadership
you're not going to pick everybody and
say I want everybody to be successful
you sound like a motivational speaker to
me I want everybody to go out there it's
great motivate inspire but you got the
one guy that wants some more than
everybody else and he's willing to work
70 hours a week these other guys don't
want to work 70 they want to go to the
nightclub on Friday night and Saturday
I don't have time for that I want to
work with this killer him build them up
that's why I want to work with Lincoln
many many years ago he's sitting there
he's like listen I need one general who
is not afraid to go to battle so he
signs the responsibility to a guy named
general McClellan many times in America
we go to different roads you'll see
McClellan Avenue McClellan Boulevard
McClellan Street why is that it's after
this general named McClellan McClellan
had one thing that it was very good
known for his soldiers were by far the
best trained soldiers out of all the
generals he had but there's one problem
with his soldiers McClellan never
thought he was ready to go to war it was
always not the right time to go to war
he would always hesitate he was a little
bit too paranoid to go to war and go to
battle because what if so this guy
Lincoln some people say the greatest
present of all time in America brings a
guy named grant Ulysses Grant Grant says
what do you want to do I want you to go
win this war 90 days Lincoln can I get a
hold of grant you know what grant does
90 days later he wins the war you know
what happens grant he becomes a
president a two-term president I don't
know if it was a good one or not but
appointed Lincoln gets credit for
picking grant grant gets credit for
having the guts that McClellan didn't
have to go to war and say what do you
guys want to do we're winning this war
here today you guys hear me we're doing
this
that's a driver he picked the right
sales guy he picked them drove him this
guy couldn't do it can you do it
I want the responsibility I'll go do it
he go he goes and does it similar thing
that happens in the world of sales is
well number three let's go over here so
now you have moral authority you're
watching me simple pad I made three
hundred thousand dollars left I'm
incredible in real estate I want to
teach six other people how to do real
estate I made four hundred thousand
dollars last time and insurance I want
to teach twenty other people how to do
the same thing great you have moral
authority to you kind of okay at picking
people and you got two or three people
you're watching that you're currently
training that you want to pick in your
office whatever it is no problem three
so now how do you drive people what are
people driven by you know what are
people driven my sauce sales meeting the
other day this guy gets up the audience
is stilled
67 year olds this is how he closes the
meeting can you imagine if one day
you're driving a Ferrari and you go into
the beach and you're at this house and
you hear the waves and it's just so
soothing it's like you're at a spa it's
amazing in these 67 euros are like this
guy need my medicine man with you what
is this guy talking about and I want to
retire I just lost three hundred
thousand dollars speak my language what
are people driven by then he got the
flip side a guy's sitting with a room of
20 year old 25 year old salespeople I
want to run through the wall and go rock
the house and a speaker can you imagine
one day being able to retire and you go
into golf course and you got the best
coach and you have this swing and the
handicap is so impressive in these 20 25
years or like dude I don't care about
golf I don't even want anything about
return I'm never going to retire what
can you give me now the language you
speak to the audience based on who
you're driving will dictate also how you
can get the best out of people so what
languages do people respond to first
things first
people will say well you know a lot of
people are driven by money you think
it's money but it's not money it's what
money gets you so let's you see I'm
sitting with this guy and I'm trying to
figure out if this is the guy for me to
work with and I want to pick him as
somebody I want to develop as a
salesperson I'll sit with them and I'll
talk to myself so Johnny tell me what do
you want to do and I want to make a lot
of money and I want to be financially
free all really why do you want to make
a lot of money well you know I want to
make a lot of money because I want to be
free why do you want to be financially
free well you know I just I just feel
like you know I saw my parents go
through a lot of struggles financially
okay so tell me what does financial
freedom look like to you oh I don't know
tell me about it what do you think what
is it is there a number to it what is it
you know I just think you know the day
my mom and dad don't have to work
anymore in my my mom's got some health
issues and the other day I came home and
some of the medication that we were
getting our health insurance doesn't
cover anyone because my dad changed his
job so those medication for my mom or
$800 now my dad can't afford it my mom
is not feeling that good and then I see
tears
then it's the heart if you think it's
just the money because this guy wants a
Mercedes Benz you absolutely lost it his
reasoning is his mother needs medication
$800 a month to paper then the father
cannot do it because he just got five he
got a new job that doesn't give him
benefits for another six months and that
hurts them so now I know exactly what
this guy's driven by the motivation is
high the inspiration is high I got a now
drive him as a leader and help him get
them because I have the moral authority
I can't direct them in some way we're
going to go do this together if you're
committed if you want to put the work in
be coachable willing to learn be a good
student I'm going to show you exactly
how to go out they make that money so
you can get to the point here so dollar
high - why until I get the medication
for Mom that costs $800 a month bingo
bingo so you say Pam what's eight
hundred bucks a month for levels of
lifestyle you got to realize number one
is survival for everybody I started in
sales purely survival parents got a
divorce my dad's at a 99-cent store I
get out of the military my mom's back in
Iran we don't have a place to live
I don't know anything nothing I got
nothing to my name it's all survival I
work at Bally's so I can survive to pay
the bills so my dad will stop having
heart attacks if he's stressed out
trying to support everybody and I can
make this money so I can take care of
the family stress is going to be lower I
want to pay off my credit card debt
because I'm so stressed out I'm at the
survival mode at that time then I go
into the status mode what is status
money I want to buy some nice cars to
impress everybody I screwed up I lost I
went from an expedition to a Ford Focus
and I went out there and I became the
guy that put all these guys in my car
and we go party together and all this
stuff we go to Newport la Hollywood San
Diego Orange County you name all these
clubs and I live into every single one
of them from 99 to 2003 I've been to all
of them if you gonder we probably ran
into each other
that was status and then I hit freedom
freedom was I want to become financially
free and once I learned that and then it
was purpose history then that was a
higher level so you need to know at what
level people around you won't know this
until you talk to them and you keep
asking them why
then you realize it so what are people
driven by here's another thing people
are driven by some people are not driven
by lifestyle some people could care less
about cars some people could care less
about watches I'm not a watch guy like
cars because I like ingenuity but I'm
not a watch guy myself I'm not a big
watch guy myself but some people don't
dribble my competition some people are
driven by competition they just want to
kill the other guy you're trying to tell
me that guy thinks he's better than me
yeah he thinks he's better than him I'm
gonna kill him who's the top salesperson
in the office is this guy he is okay
what did he do last month what do I need
to do he comes in earlier he leaves
later because he wants to be number one
so it's competitive then the other guys
driven by breaking records who owns a
record here for such-and-such I want to
break all the records what are the
records I want to break the records
every single record I want to break all
the records somewhat competitive but
it's about you know I want to do
something that's never been done before
third one is fighting for cause hey what
is a cause what we're doing here we're
going to be able to raise $1,000,000 so
we can go back and build homes and do
such-and-such what we're doing here
we're going to be able to make a lot of
money so we can build homes to help
people out what we're doing here we're
going to be able to teach the spirit of
capitalism and free enterprise to
millions of people around the world so
they realize a person out there that
just like pbd he was nothing he was
small he had nothing going on no example
mom and dad they're trying to figure out
their own lives I'm a little kid and I
realized in the world the world of
capitalism a regular average guy like me
can rise up and say phone let's go get
him baby if you got a dream let's go get
him if we got a dream now why should I
fight for this cause person says let you
say I buy into this cause your job as
the leader with moral authority your job
is to show the salesperson if we go and
fight this cause you individually will
get X Y Z and you wouldn't make for
yourself and collectively we'll do
something that's never been done before
that's a language you speak to people
but I need to also know what's going to
happen to my life not just a collective
effort when my dreams become a reality
yes it will and last but not least I can
do this for hours there's a lot of other
points I'm just giving you a flavor of
it here today
the other one is enemy who's the enemy
everyone's got an enemy you better
believe I've got enemies and I just
enemies ain't you know people that see
me as a target enemies I have a good
memory and some of my enemies follow
value tainment I've got a very good
memory in our member names I have
enemies
everybody has enemies what is an enemy
to you an enemy could have been a
schoolteacher and enemy could have been
a spirit in you that you're trying to
get rid of that's holding you back an
enemy could be a small think inside of
you an enemy could be somebody that's
you that's within here what is the enemy
an enemy could be a target an enemy
could be a lot of different things that
you're dealing but it's not just because
of it's not just because of one thing or
one person or competition or an enemy
could be a lot of different things that
you're dealing with okay we're talking
any kind of an enemy enemies get people
to wake up and go after think about a
lot of people say well you know there is
no enemy or basketball are you kidding
me if your name is Cleveland Cavaliers
guess who your number one enemy years
now you may say yourself and that's true
but you better get to the Golden State
Golden State's got to get through
Cleveland if you want that championship
ring there's an enemy and people some
people are driven by that you may be
watching this right now saying I don't
care about that you're not just trying
to talk to you I'm not just talking to
you right now I'm talking to how to go
from sales to sales leader and not
everybody is driven the same way
sometimes people make the mistake
thinking just because you're not
competitive that other people aren't
driven by competition sometimes you
think because you are so almighty and
you know you don't care about what other
peoples are you just about I want to be
the best that I can be that's Creed
where you're at but not everybody's
wired like you so how are you going to
drive somebody that's not wired by that
no we're certain kids in high school now
I wanted to fight 101
hey let's go after school let's fight
okay and it would start the fight I want
to fight then there were kids that could
care less about fighting but if you came
to their group and you said something to
their group and a brawl broke out and
somebody got bullied this guy shows up
out of nowhere coming and saying you
don't ever think about bullying this kid
here and woopsy still he's driven by a
different thing than the other guy said
I want to fight you one-on-one
everyone's driven in a different way you
got to figure out how to drive yourself
then if you want to be yourselves you
got learn how to drive everybody else
surround you that's what great sales
leaders by the way that's what great
leaders do period Popovich Reilly MLK
president leaders generals CEOs
Hollywood's you talk to Hollywood actors
when they were working under a director
that said film said something to him and
he got emotional he got into this role
he started crying and you and I watched
a movie were like oh my gosh
what an incredible actor you don't know
what the director said that actors mind
during that moment which says hey come
here that was that take let me tell you
do you remember that one time has this
ever happened to you tell me about your
mom tell me about your dad tell me about
this coming about that you remember that
moment yeah how did it feel when that
person talked to your mom like that how
did it feel when that person talked to
her dad like that I want to see that
feeling on the camera right now go think
about it right now show it to me I want
to feel it the actors in tears he goes
in a moment he comes out boom then you
and I see an Oscar winner it's because
the director drove somebody that's what
it is trap to this here once we figure
this part out I think I were four is
here learning how to drive you tie their
reasons to result in a deadline here's
what I want I want to make the $800 for
my mom you need to do XYZ amount of
calls knocking doors whatever you want
to call the activity in your business
and you need to do this many every
single day every single week for the
next three months and if you do it every
single day every single week deadline
everyday deadline every week deadline 12
weeks deadline one month if you do this
90 days form they're going to make this
and your mom will never worry about date
hundred dollars mom because you've
learned how to make that money give it
to your mom every single month and she
looks at you're saying that's my son I'm
proud of your baby I'm proud of you baby
how do we do what we do you think this
whole thing is about making money and
becoming famous you know everywhere we
go nowadays oh my gosh you're actually
dividing this thing just a thing stuff
getting people to experience the juice
in their own lives that's exciting so
number one is tie their reasons to a
result in a deadline number two break it
down by size bytes so you know if you
want to make a million dollars let's
back up your cut if you want to make a
hundred thousand dollars back up if you
made a make you break it down and you
give me a formula for me to know
I need to do this month next month next
month next month next month and then
when you start working with some people
that are people you pick to our solid
people you pick to be able to work with
then it comes down to your
accountability then it comes down to you
studying their trends and it comes down
to your weekly report then it comes down
to you believing in them injecting
belief in them seeing who they could be
reminding them or why they're doing this
constantly reminding people what they're
capable of doing and three months six
months 12 months 24 months down the line
five years down you're gonna look at
them and say oh my gosh I cannot believe
that just took place right now I cannot
believe that I just had a guy Rodolfo
necessity Vargas husband a wife from El
Salvador come to America works at Sears
he was an economist in El Salvador
barely making any money they come to the
States you work in and go from making
$20,000 a year income to making $175,000
in a month injecting belief and
tournelle man there's somebody you
follow these guys they get you in motion
when you see some of these stories and
these types of stories go on and on and
on and on and on in many different
stories as long as you learn the secret
to scaling your sales team which is
learning how to drive people so having
said that again I'm not going too much
into details because it'd be a one-day
session with you on this topic I'm
giving you you know bite sizes for you
to think about it and process it on your
own and go figure out where you need to
be doing by doing the proper research
and find ways to get better at that so
with that being said if you got any
questions you got any thoughts comment
on the bottom let me get the pillow
right there mr. Andrew see if you can
catch this question thoughts comment on
the bottom if you have not subscribed to
this channel yet click on the subscribe
button right here and on the little
alert button
Louise make this a little bit bigger
okay on this alert button right down
there to be part of the notification
squad and we'll go from there take
everybody
[Music]